[Musique]
en ce milieu du mois de septembre 1982
il fait encore une chaleur écrasante du
côté de servium en Haute-Corse
les derniers touristes se prélassent sur
les plages
ignorant qu'à quelques centaines de
mètres de là une guerre fait rage
[Musique]
dans le milieu un règlement de compte ce
n'est pas une affaire d'amateur
lorsqu'on doit tuer rien ne doit être
laissé au hasard
on note d'abord les habitudes de la
cible ses horaires ces trajets réguliers
surtout on choisit bien le lieu du crime
à l'abri des regards autant que possible
la cible c'est le gérant d'une
discothèque à la mode un certain Daniel
Ziglioli
[Musique]
il est 18h20 lorsque le commerçant
arrive à son entrepôt
il ne voit pas les deux hommes cachés
derrière un bosquet en embuscade
[Musique]
les tueurs ont tiré 8 fois
signant leur crime d'une dernière balle
dans la bouche
sur les lieux du crime personne n'a rien
vu rien entendu
mais après trois mois d'enquête les
policiers corses arrêtent trois hommes
Robert Moracchini d'abord suspecté
d'être l'auteur des coups de feu
puis deux complices présumées Georges
seattelli et Pierre-Marie Santucci
interpellé dans une plante en possession
d'un véritable arsenal
en Corse l'affaire fait grand bruit
d'autant plus que les trois suspects
présumés font partie d'un tout jeune
clan qui fait régner la terreur sur
l'île et inspire la plus grande crainte
jusque sur le continent
le quartier du Palais de justice de
Dijon sous haute surveillance durant le
procès de trois corses auteurs présumées
du meurtre d'un commerçant de
Haute-Corse le 14 septembre 82
Robert Moracchini Pierre-Marie Santucci
et George satelli sont depuis ce matin
les accusés les mieux gardés de France
de procès les tueurs présumés du gérant
de la discothèque qui débute à Dijon
fait souffler un vent de panique dans la
ville
80 policiers c'est restent tireurs
d'élite maître chien et une équipe de
déminage ont été mobilisés pour les
quatre jours que durera le procès
transformant le palais de justice en une
véritable forteresse comme si
brusquement toute la mythologie Corse
c'était décentralisée sur le continent
clairement Dijon ville assiéger il y
avait un cordon CRS tout autour du
palais
ils avaient terriblement peur de ce qui
se passait c'était quand même des
personnages très dangereux déjà à
l'époque
trop trop le d'identité il faut ici
systématique des témoins et de
l'assistance ce n'est que l'un des
aspects de l'énorme dispositif policier
installée dans et autour du palais de
justice de Dijon pour assurer comme on
dit la sérénité des débats
j'entrais dans cette salle d'audience
tous des Corses avec les Ray-Ban
Lunettes de soleil
que le provocatrice qui n'hésitait pas à
se montrer très provoquant
[Musique]
effectivement les gens qui étaient dans
cette salle n'étaient pas peut-être pas
des Bourguignons la salle était pleine
de Corse parce qu'ils avaient beaucoup
d'amis ces gens là
vous sentez que vous êtes obligé de vous
serrer les coudes avec les deux
personnes qui sont sur les banc et les
clients nous contre une salle tout
entière qui vous était hostile on était
encerclés par Bastia qui avait débarqué
à Dijon
la menace est omniprésente et
l'inquiétude à la hauteur de la sinistre
réputation des trois accusés
c'est vrai que nous avions contre nous
le rapport des renseignements généraux
le
ceux qui traînait autour de nos clients
les renseignements de la police et
cetera évidemment c'était pas très bon
ce procès qui s'annonce très mouvementé
et d'abord celui de ce jeune clan
ce groupe criminel alors en pleine
ascension
la brise de mer
la brise de mer c'est le plus grand
groupe criminel que la France est connue
depuis la deuxième guerre mondiale
la brise de mer c'est un système mafieux
une nébuleuse qui regroupe plusieurs
centaines de personnes à tous les
échelons de la société
à la tête du clan on compte une douzaine
d'hommes des figures du grand banditisme
parmi lesquels ne se distingue aucun
chef et qui se doivent une solidarité
absolue
ah c'est déjà charisme c'était des vrais
voleurs des vrais maillots de l'époque
[Musique]
c'était des gens qui avaient des belles
voitures qui étaient physiquement pas
mal donc il suscité une certaine
fascination la brise de mer elle interne
la naissance d'un système mafieux en
Corse elle va importer une violence
brutale impitoyable
ça a été dans l'histoire le gang le plus
puissant influent il faisait peur
c'était une grosse grosse équipe que
fait trembler le milieu
le plus violente le plus astucieuse qui
ont plus réussi à passer entre les
gouttes de la justice et de la police
à son apogée c'était vraiment l'image
c'était peut-être une des plus grands
équipes d'Europe c'était l'équivalent de
la mafia en Sicile crois-moi
en 30 ans d'araignes sans partage la
brise demeure aura tout connu les
braquages de banque ou de fourgon
blindés les casses organisés de mains de
maître les règlements de comptes
sanglants
la prison parfois les évasions et les
cavales surtout
elle a construit un empire en
investissant dans l'économie légale
les travaux publics les restaurants les
bars les discothèques et cercles de jeu
le tourisme de luxe le football
financièrement c'est énorme c'est des
centaines de millions c'est des
entreprises dans le monde entier c'est
une multinationale
les parrains du clan Bastien se sont
invités à la table des grandes ce monde
tutoyant des chefs d'État africains ce
lion avec des hommes politiques français
et des hommes d'affaires influents
la brise de mer encore ont l'appelait le
plus souvent la brise mais c'est un nom
que peut oser
je crois qu'il faut pas il faut pas en
parler
la croix
un silence de mort entoure l'histoire de
la brise de mer
[Musique]
une histoire qui commence ici à Bastia à
la fin des années 70 dans le cœur
historique de la ville
à l'abri des murailles de la citadelle
et des deux Campanile de Saint-Jean le
vieux port demeure le joyau de Bastien
lui qui a été le premier port de la
ville a depuis longtemps désormais pour
vocation la brise de mer au début ce
n'est que le nom d'un modeste débit de
boisson situé sur le vieux port
aujourd'hui le bar s'appelle plus
sobrement le Méditerranée
[Musique]
il y avait des gens quand même assez
différents les gens qui étaient des de
bonnes familles des gens qui ont fait
des études et à côté il y a des gens qui
ont vécu dans les quartiers difficiles
de partir à tout ça
et ils se sont rapprochés je pense par
une certaine mentalité
une mentalité de voyous d'autant que le
patron du bar un ancien polar n'est
autre que l'oncle de Pierre-Marie
Santucci
et pourtant dans ce groupe nombreux sont
ceux que rien ne prédestinait à basculer
dans le banditisme
[Musique]
pour vous dire à quel point on n'est pas
dans la dans la dans la voie du crassie
de père en fils il est fils et
petit-fils de notaire on a dans sa
généalogie des gouverneurs de la France
coloniale Robert Moracchini qui est un
autre pilier de la brise sa soeur est
médecin son père ou sa mère travaille au
Trésor public etc etc
ce sont des gens qu'on pignon sur rue
qui ne sont pas du tout contraints de
vouloir assassiner ou racketter pour
vivre leur famille au départ a une vie
bourgeoise ils ne vivent pas aux banc de
la société ils sont totalement intégrés
dans la société corse dans son histoire
sa géographie sa culture mais ça ne leur
suffit pas ils veulent prendre le
pouvoir économique et politique
[Musique]
pour s'emparer du pouvoir la brise de
mer naissante doit d'abord se faire un
nom éliminer toute résistance
du nettoyage c'est les bonnes assassins
faut pas croire quand ils vont sur un
mec le mec il est mort et il y a pas de
blessés
[Musique]
en Haute-Corse au début des années 80 un
clan fait la loi depuis près de 20 ans
avec à sa tête un certain Louis mimi
[Musique]
pour moi c'était un oncle c'était le
frère de mon père et c'était un être qui
en imposait qui était oui qui était
assez effrayant oui moi j'étais assez
effrayé par cette oncle c'était le
parrain de l'époque
officiellement à 50 ans Louis n'est que
le patron d'un restaurant très fréquenté
de la ville de Corte mais en réalité
c'est lui qui tient toute la région avec
une pointe de fer
il était connu dans toute la Corse il
était très aimé pour beaucoup de choses
et en même temps très craint aussi alors
l'amour et la crainte
malfaiteur de combines au sein de la
Corse mais c'était beaucoup plus
élu gang rural ou agricole quoi oui même
c'était des personnages un peu à
l'ancienne un peu parce que un peu de
films un peu pittoresque dans le
fonctionnement
les conflits entre malfrat pour que tout
se passe pour le mieux dans cette
société là ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que quand tu avais un problème tu
allais pas voir les flics ça ça se
faisait pas d'aller voir le chef du clan
pour qu'il règle lui le problème ou tu
lui demandais de te protéger
offre donc sa protection aux
entrepreneurs et aux commerçants qui
exercent sur son territoire
moyennant et change de bons et loyaux
services
et gare à ceux qui ne se soumettraient
pas à l'autorité du parrain de Corte
oui
c'était un type très dangereux lui il
avait du sang sur les mains
et chercher la peur chez les autres
parce qu'il ne la connaissait pas
lui-même
depuis toujours le chef du clan de Corte
est un coriace
mais les jeunes de la brise sont des
têtes brûlées que rien n'arrête
d'autant plus que lui m'a mis est à la
tête d'une petite fortune grâce à des
machines à souples placer dans les
bistrots
le parrain en possède encore mais
surtout sur le continent
mais moi je suis là
si elle faisait 1000 euros il y avait
500 pour le quartier et 500 pour le mec
qui avait la machine
et il vivait de ça les mains qui se
faisaient 30 000 euros par mois ah ouais
ça rapporte ouais à l'époque ça
rapportait
un véritable jackpot dont les jeunes
loups de la brise de mer voudraient bien
s'emparer
alors pour commencer ils vont défier
l'autorité du vieux parrain de Corte sur
son propre territoire
la discothèque Le Castel est connu pour
être sous la protection du clan des
la boîte de nuit gérée par Daniel
Ziglioli est devenu en quelques années
le rendez-vous incontournable des jeunes
de la région
et ce soir là Pierre-Marie San Tucci et
George Seatelli membre de la brise de
mer naissance n'ont qu'une intention de
s'y amuser
[Musique]
vont arriver avec une arme et ils vont
exercer une pression classique du genre
la bouteille c'est pour toi ou
le monde de la nuit c'est sa partie en
voyous c'est pas aux années de Jean ce
genre de choses
les jeunes voyous de la brise sont venus
pour fixer de nouvelles règles
à commencer par le racket qu'il voudrait
imposer au gérant des lieux
Daniel zeglioli il a pas peur des gens
de la brise de mer c'est des gens qui
sont pas connus c'est des jeunes et il
va les expulser ces vigoureusement de la
boîte de nuit
et là on passe à une échelle de violence
supérieure c'est là que les règlements
de compte vont commencer
Daniel zigli fait alors appel à son
protecteur oui mais me
il sera calmer ses fauteuils et éviter
des représailles
Louis retrouve les deux Bastien et leur
inflige une correction à sa façon oui
Mimi il a fait mettre à genoux George
satelli il a braqué le calibre sur la
tête il a dit de domaine pardon il a
humilié
le mec qui tue Millie il te met une
calibre sur la tête il te dit mets-toi à
genoux ça peut pas passer ça chez les
voyous ça peut pas passer si tu passes à
ça tu es tu es une merde le mec il faut
qu'il meurt lui tout le monde
[Musique]
sans le savoir c'est une déclaration de
guerre que vient de signer lui
une guerre qui commence dans ses
montagnes avec un règlement de comptes à
l'ancienne et dans les règles de l'art
la brise de mer va signer son acte de
naissance par un meurtre
avec une arme très archaïque que les
Siciliens appellent le loup parrain
[Musique]
un fusil à canon siècle qui offre un
immense avantage
la chevrotine retrouvée dans le corps de
la victime échappe à l'analyse
balistique impossible dès lors
d'identifier l'arme du crime et son
propriétaire
pour les tueurs fabriquer un loupera est
un jeu d'enfant
il leur suffit d'abord de trouver un
simple fusil de chasse dont il coupe le
canon bien court au plus proche de la
longueur
grâce à cette opération la dispersion
des projectiles leur assure de tuer sur
le coup leur victime à condition de
tirer quasiment à beau portant
enfin il coupe la crosse de façon à le
conserver que la poignée du fusil
l'arme ainsi raccourcie permet plus
facilement de la dissimuler sous un
manteau ou une veste longue
10 septembre 1981 il est 4h du matin
lorsque Louis mai rentre chez lui après
une nuit à jouer aux cartes
soudain deux hommes sortent de l'ombre
un premier tir atteint le parrain de
Corte à hauteur du bras gauche
puis les tueurs vise le thorax et le
cœur
[Musique]
on est en 1981 j'ai à peu près 15 ans et
on nous annonce l'assassinat de mon
oncle
et donc on se précipite toute la famille
se précipite à son restaurant
et ce qui m'a frappé à ce moment-là
c'est cette forme blanche tracée par les
policiers sur le sol
c'est traumatisant quand vous le vivez
c'est quelque chose qui vous marque
parce que cette forme elle sera toujours
là
elle est toujours dans mon esprit
[Musique]
pour les Corses l'assassinat de Louis
fait l'effet d'une bombe
et ses funérailles n'auront rien à
envier à celle d'un chef d'État
on dit toujours dans la famille il y
avait toute l'accords
[Musique]
alors que tous s'interrogent sur
l'identité des tueurs de louis-mémi
un témoin sort du silence pour dire ce
qu'il a vu cette nuit là juste après le
meurtre
les auteurs de l'assassinat s'enfuient
et dans la course perd un fusil dans le
maquis
et tout ça sous les yeux d'un témoin
qu'il ne voit pas qui est un berger
Joseph Paturel
Joseph pacciani va très vite faire le
lien entre cet étrange scène et le
meurtre de lui-même
le berger est un incorrigible bavard qui
parle le haut et fort et ne peut
s'empêcher de raconter à qui veut bien
l'entendre dans son village de
karakuchiha ce qu'il a vu ce matin du 17
septembre
il y a une bonne âme qui va relayer le
ce qui a raconté le berger
et nous on dit quoi
celui qui parle ça descend sec sur lui
il meurt il meurt mais sèchement
dans un premier temps il va y avoir une
tentative d'assassinat sur le berger qui
va qui va le blesser à l'épaule
il va être hospitalisé
et il y a un commando de deux personnes
qui vont aller le chercher dans une
chambre d'hôpital
avec un sang froid qualifié par les
personnels soignants d'extraordinaire
et ils vont tuer le berger sur son lit
d'hôpital
[Musique]
l'élimination du berger seul témoin
d'humeurtre de Louis réduit à néant le
travail des enquêteurs
l'affaire sera classée sans suite
la nuit qui suit sera meurtrière
[Musique]
la guerre qui oppose la brise de mer au
clanémie et celle de l'Ancien et du
Nouveau Monde
et le jeune clan de Bastia ne fait pas
de quartier éliminant tous ceux qui
refusent de lui prêter allégeance
des exécutions sommaires ou les tueurs
n’hésitent pas à acheter leur victime
d'une balle dans la bouche
la signature macabre de la brise
ou celui qui est susceptible de prendre
la relève pour en fait ce sont des
engrenages morbides les jeunes qui
c'est pas qu'on veut prendre la place on
la prend maintenant on va tuer pour
montrer qu'on est là et faire des
exemples et on veut même pas discuter il
y a pas de discussion oui mais non ça on
sanctionne de suite
et comme ils étaient soudés rusé
audacieux ben ça leur a souri à la fin
ben ils étaient craint redouté voilà
quand vous hésitez pas tué vous êtes
créé et redouter
[Musique]
dans leur crime les genoux de la brise
demeure se montrent d'une redoutable
précisément
et devant ses meurtres qui se suivent et
se ressemblent les enquêteurs n'ont pas
l'ombre d'une piste encore moins d'un
témoin
si on sait trop ce qu'il advient à ceux
qui ose parler
et pendant ce temps la brise elle semble
invulnérable
jusqu'à ce jour du mois de septembre
1982 où les tueurs de la brise vont
finir par commettre une imprudence
l'élimination de Daniel Ziglioli les
gérant de la discothèque Le Castel ne
devait être qu'une simple formalité
mais l'affaire va se compliquer
car suite au meurtre un automobiliste a
été témoin d'une étrange saine et cette
fois l'homme n'a pas peur de parler et
pour cause c'est un policier
donc c'est un fonctionnement de la PAF
un policier traversant un moment donné
un pont il aperçoit une voiture en face
et des gens qui le connais notamment
Robert Morini pilier de la brise de mer
il le voit lancer quelque chose au
dessus du pont
il poursuit sa route
et là d'un coup il arrive dans la ville
qui suit et il s'aperçoit qu'un homicide
vient d'être commis Daniel zeglioli
vient d'être assassiné
qui a pu jeter Robert Moracchini du haut
de ce pont
le policière raconte ce qu'il a vu aux
enquêteurs qui décide immédiatement de
faire draguer les eaux du fleuve
il y découvre un pistolet automatique de
type colt 45
et coup de bol c'est l'arme qui a servi
à tuer Daniel egli
Robert Moracchini et ses deux complices
font la une de la presse locale
pour les Corses plus aucun doute n'est
possible c'est bien la brise de mer qui
se livre à ce jeu de massacre
et dans l'affaire Ziglioli les trois
jeunes piliers de la brise ont de quoi
être inquiet
Moracchini a été identifié par un
policier alors qu'il se débarrassait de
l'arme du crime c'est atelier ont été
reconnus par d'autres témoins et
interpellé pour complicité de meurtre
pour une affaire criminelle c'est
beaucoup d'éléments la justice n'a pas
si souvent que ça autant d'éléments pour
poursuivre des gens
[Musique]
juste ici donc avec l'ouverture ce matin
à Dijon du procès en assise les auteurs
présumés de l'assassinat de Daniel
zillioli le procès devait se dérouler à
Bastia mais la cour d'assise de
Haute-Corse avait été décaissi de cette
affaire et cela pourrait éviter des
pressions contre les jurés vous avez eu
cette idée d'aller à Dijon pour ne pas
qui est de pression dans l'atmosphère
Corse c'est la première affaire je pense
qu'il dépayse pour ça considérant que la
justice à Dijon sera moins susceptible
d'être mis sous pression menacée
intimidé à une époque à Bastia la
condensé ne fonctionnait pas bien
nous avions les acquittements à
répétition nous avions des fois du mal à
constituer les cours d'assises fallait
au moins 25 ou 30 jurés on se retrouve
un jour on vous rappelle on a trouvé 4
il y a eu des acquittements alors qu'il
y avait des preuves pour leur faire
prendre 20 ans
[Musique]
c'est quasiment un flagrant délit aux
assises ça ne se voit jamais et un
flagrant délit pris par des policiers
c'est une hypothèse d'école ça n'arrive
jamais
donc c'est vrai que j'arrive
relativement tranquille sur le résultat
attendu j'ai pas beaucoup d'inquiétudes
parce que ça peut pas être autrement on
a la preuve c'est clair
Christine courage et donc l'avocat de la
famille de Daniel Ziglioli
et face à elle elle retrouvait l'un des
ténors du barreau Henri Leclerc
approchait quelques mois plus tôt par
des proches de la brise de mer
les bons de demander si je pouvais
entrer dans cette affaire qui était
quand même particulièrement grave pour
défendre Robert maracini qui était
accusé de la clôture
l'ouverture du process se fait dans une
atmosphère très lourde
face à un public hostile aux victimes et
à ceux qui les défendent
c'est pas possible de ne pas avoir peur
quand on est dans cette salle d'audience
avec ses trois accusés dans le box
moi-même je peux vous dire que quand je
l'ai été fusillé du regard par l'un des
trois j'en ai pas large
avocat et magistrats sont sous pression
il faut dire que les renseignements
généraux ont signalé la présence d'une
vingtaine de véhicules immatriculés en
Corse circulant dans la ville dont une
rutilante Ferrari de couleur jaune
c'est une des armes du clan Bastié on
fait d'abord planer une menace sourde
dans l'environnement du procès une
inquiétude qui malgré vous s'installe
durablement
on voyait des voitures 2B qui freinaient
à son cowboy au feu rouge s'arrêtait qui
repartait à grand renfort de crissement
de pneus et puis il y a des arrivages en
avion tous les jours et les
renseignements généraux surveillaient ça
avec
certaines inquiétudes parce que c'était
pas l'habitude de la ville de Dijon faut
bien le dire
lors de la première matinée des débats
le président de la course se montre
plutôt combatif face à cette hostilité
ambiante
avant de soudain changer de ton
le président était au début il était
assez agressif plus petit à petit il est
devenu de moins en moins c'est vrai mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe et puis
au bout d'un quart d'heure je me tourne
avec mon frère je dis mais ils ont été
touchés alors du déjeuner et ils m'ont
tous dit évidemment tu as raison bien
sûr
toucher ça veut dire qu'on a approché
d'une manière ou d'une autre le juge le
procureur ou même le jury qu'on a fait
passer un message et que le message a
été reçu
c'était surréaliste
les jurés ont été d'une discrétion
absolument totale j'en ai pas vu un seul
poser une question on les a pas entendus
on les a pas vu la seule chose que j'ai
vu c'était un président métamorphosé
entre le matin et l'après-midi du 1er
jour et puis surtout une attitude
incompréhensible et complètement
inhabituelle vis-à-vis des avocats des
parties civils j'ai jamais vu
à chaque fois que on essayait
d'intervenir on se faisait rabouer il a
défense était en pays conquis dès le
départ dès le premier jour toucher des
gens ça me paraît quand même même dans
ces années-là particulièrement difficile
mais alors est-ce que ça a eu lieu moi
je vais pas la preuve que ça n'a pas eu
lieu mais je crois que je n'ai pas de
preuve que ça a eu lieu la brise de leur
truc c'était que quand un deux passé aux
assises ils essayaient dans la journée
du procès entre midi et deux de soudoyer
les jurés la brise isamboyait des jeunes
et le mec il allait au jury il lui
disait tiens on vous donne
50000 francs vous votez qu'il est pas
coupable
c'est une méthode qui a beau avoir fait
ses preuves elle est très loin d'être
infaillible
le problème principal restant le
témoignage du policier qui a reconnu
formellement Moracchini sur le pont
et on sait combien la parole d'un
fonctionnaire à fermenté vaut de l'or
tout d'abord il refuse de d'aller
témoigner à Dijon dans un premier temps
il avance un prétexte fallacieux
finalement sous la menace de sa
hiérarchie et de la justice il finit par
venir
le policier devant la barre ça me fait
malheureusement qu'annoncer tout ce que
va être le procès c'est-à-dire une
débandade de A jusqu'à Z de tous les
témoins
je l'ai interrogé sur les contradictions
que j'avais remarquées dans son
témoignage vous savez il y a souvent les
contradictions et je me rappelle que ce
policier a au fur et à mesure reconnu
que c'était pas lui effectivement il se
souvient pas il s'est trompé il avait il
avait cru voir mais en fait c'était une
erreur
les policiers déclare je n'ai pas
reconnu mort Acquigny j'ai bien vu un
homme jeté quelque chose à l'eau mais je
n'ai reconnu personne
c'est évidemment une bombe qui tombe au
milieu de la salle d'audience
il n'y a pas été très combatif le
président mais tout de même là c'était
tellement énorme qu'il a été obligé de
pousser le témoin danseur franchement il
finit par lui avouer qu'il a peur
pousser à bout le policier l'âge dans un
murmure je craignais des représailles
contre ma famille
moi en tant qu'avocat je me dis bon
c'est pas grave personne ne peut marcher
là dedans
la suite montrer Rach malheureusement
c'est pas comme ça que ça s'est passé
[Musique]
je me souviens
du témoignage du joueur de foot mais
c'était c'était impressionnant parce
qu'il était plus jeune
c'était moi ce sont des joueurs du
Sporting Club de Bastia tout simplement
l'équipe de football la plus titrée et
la plus populaire de Corse
quelques années auparavant elle a même
remporté la Coupe de France face à l'AS
Saint-Étienne de Michel Platini
[Applaudissements]
à Dijon ce ne sont pas moins de 9
joueurs qui se déplacent pour juré
devant le tribunal qu'au moment précis
du crémant les trois accusés jouaient au
football avec eux
la stupéfaction absolue j'avais jamais
vu ça
évidemment puisqu'il venait dire qu'à
l'heure du crime ces gens-là étaient au
stade toute l'équipe de foot qui vient
dire rigoureusement le contraire de ce
qui est dans les procès-verbaux
[Musique]
il y a toujours au moins 7 8 personnes
mais honorable surtout on aurable qui
vont venir témoigner qui vont dire mais
il était avec moi je jure devant toutes
les assises du monde quand il était avec
au moins à telle heure à tel endroit
mais ce n'est pas tout quelques minutes
plus tard un nouveau témoin vient porter
le coup de grâce à l'accusation
Christian Léonie le propre cousin de la
victime Daniel Ziglioli vient confirmer
la présence des accusés au stade la
famille le prend à partie et lui lance
combien ont à payer et tu vas encore
fleurir la tombe de ton cousin
mais Christian Léonie s'est déjà trouvé
une autre famille
sur cette photo datant de l'année du
procès il pose fièrement dans l'équipe
menée par le frère d'un des accusés
Francis en Tucci membre éminent de la
brise de mer
à la fin du procès les délibérations des
jurés ne vont guère traîner
expédier en moins de 30 minutes
presque un record pour un procès en
assise j'arrive dans la salle d'audience
le ciel me tombe sur la tête quand on
vous dit mes jambes se sont dérobées
sous moi mais là c'était vraiment
physiquement ce qui s'est passé
pour les faits d'homicide volontaire et
complicité d'assassinat de Daniel zigli
la cour prononce la quêtement de Robert
Morini Georges c'est attelli et
Pierre-Marie
[Musique]
ils avaient gagné c'était la victoire
au cours de 6 de gens qui sont détenus
c'est toujours quelque chose d'assez la
race
[Musique]
un sourire jusqu'aux oreilles nous
regardait on a gagné et c'était
clairement de la provocation
ce procès là ça sera dans l'opinion
insulaire notamment et surtout la
naissance de l'impunité d'un brise de
mer ça montrait que finalement ils
étaient non seulement terrain conquis
chez eux mais évidemment aussi sur tout
le territoire d'un temps tout le monde
le comprenait si ce sorte de là il
sortiront de tout
c'est ça le message
en Corse le message est passé
[Musique]
et pour la famille de Daniel Ziglioli
l'accablement succède à la colère
d'autant plus que quelques années
avancent procès le frère de la victime
Gérard Ziglioli avait lui aussi tenté de
rendre justice
à sa façon
nous vous le venger son frère tout
simplement même si lui c'est pas un
noyau chez nous quand on fera ce fait
tuer bah c'est comme ça
[Musique]
tu ne peux pas faire autrement
tu ne peux pas
tu le participes pas à la Vendette comme
tu dois le faire
plus personne te parle
la Vendée
et il va commencer très fort
dimanche soir au bar de la brise de mer
tout est calme lorsqu'un client entre et
s'attard sans que personne ne le
remarque un drôle de clients en vérité
quelques secondes plus tard une terrible
explosion sème la panique une charge de
200 g venait d'être lancée dans la
première salle mais aujourd'hui on
s'interroge qui pouvait en vouloir à se
battre tranquille de Bastia le moins que
l'on puisse dire
son frère et lui il est rentré dans le
bar de la brise de mer il envoyait un
engin explosif ouais le mec il a fait
force ce jour-là c'est-à-dire il a eu le
courage il aura envoyé une bombe dans le
bar
la bombe ne fait que quelques blessés
légers et ne touche personne de la brise
de mer absente du bar ce jour-là
son frère a insisté son mépris à la
maison de campagne de Georgia attelli
avec des explosifs encore bon il y avait
personne mais assez effondré comme un
château de cartes
et ça se répéter de Gérard zeglioli ne
déstabilise pas la maryse bien au
contraire
nous retrouver ils ont fait une
opération commando avec tout le monde et
tout le monde là ils sont allés en
fourgon devant la maison de sa sœur je
crois voilà c'était fini quoi
le 14 avril 1983 Gérard Ziglioli est
assassiné par un véritable commando
une douzaine d'hommes sur armées sorties
d'une camionnette
les enquêteurs ont beaucoup comprendre
d'où vient le coup ils n'ont là encore
aucun indice aucun témoin pour espérer
mettre à l'ombre les auteurs du crime
les policiers en sont réduits à faire
les comptes
dans leur rapport il dresse le bilan de
la guerre mené contre l'ancien clan de
Louis
un conte macabre de 19 morts
de l'autre il vaut mieux que je le tue
avant qu'il me tue et c'est des
engrenages sordides mais engrenages
quand même comme ça parce que ça vole
bas ça c'est un terre-à-terre c'est
animal ce sont beaucoup de meurtres mais
il faut comprendre aussi qu'il y avait
les profits colossaux notamment à cette
époque là les jeux les machines à sous
en particulier qui ramenaient des des
sommes colossales colossales peut-être
plus que les studies à ce moment
une fois qu'ils ont éliminé le clan
émises ont repris toutes leurs affaires
leurs machines à sous de l'époque tout
ce qui avisent à nous
la brise de mer vient de mettre la main
sur un véritable pactole et pour
augmenter encore la mise elle va imposer
ses règles à de nouveaux cafetiers
mais il y avait beaucoup de commerçants
dégagé que ça soit sur le continent ou
encore sinon on dit il y a plus de
machines pour vous c'est nous les voyous
qui prennent les machines
et après si le mec il comprenait pas il
le frappe sa je l'ai vu de mes yeux vu
il en plâtre dans le bar et lui disait
tu vas donner toutes les clés des
monnayeurs des machines avec tous les
comptes et tout
après si le mec il comprend pas il le
tue lui son fils tous les mecs qui se
mettent devant il est dégagent
avec cette prise de guerre la brise
vient de passer à la vitesse supérieure
désormais plus rien n'arrête les jeunes
parents pour s'emparer de ce territoire
qui les a vu naître
une conquête qui va encore s'accélérer
car en ce milieu des années 80 la Corse
connaît une croissance sans précédent
un développement économique en Corse qui
est plus important il y a du tourisme
qui se développe donc il y a plus
d'argent il y a plus d'affaires et à
plus de construction il y a plus
d'argent à prendre
les ferries font le plein jusqu'en Corse
où les touristes viennent dépenser leurs
économies dans les établissements de
Lille
une aubaine pour la brise qui va placer
son argent dans des affaires très
lucratives
la brise de mer et la diversifié sont
blanchiment et ses sources
d'investissement ces membres vont
investir ici dans un bar ici un bar
tabac ou là une boîte de nuit
[Musique]
sur les cendres du clanémie la brise de
mer s'accaparent des discothèques
qu'elle reprend sous main
le bibelots et le Starlight à Calvin le
palladium à Saint-Florent le Mina est à
Servian le New Club devenu l'aventure à
Corte
c'est d'investissement c'est ce qui va
leur permettre ensuite de ne plus être
un gang criminel classique c'est ce qui
va leur permettre de corrompre c'est ce
qui va leur permettre de blanchir des
sommes colossales
[Musique]
insatiable la brise investie dans la
construction de nouveaux établissements
qui vont devenir les fleurons de la nuit
en Corse le challenger à l'Île Rousse ou
encore l'Apocalypse à Bastia inauguré en
grande pompe par une star internationale
Alain Delon qu'on dit proche de certains
membres de la brise de mer
les jeunes par un flambent et affichent
désormais sans détour leur insolent
réussite
moi je me souviens 85 je suis allé à
Bastia on m'a montré la Porsche 928
comme il avait Al Pacino dans Scarface
on m'a dit c'est la Porsche de Robert
Moracchini de la brise
morachini fraîchement relaxé ce Pava ne
volant de sa luxueuse voiture de sport
il était à la tête d'affaires juteuse de
bars restaurant très bien placé au cœur
de la ville sur la place Saint-Nicolas
face à ce succès fulgurant la police
s'interroge comment mettre fin à
l'impunité aller résistible ascension de
la brise
avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
les années sont passées on ne les a pas
réellement arrêtés ni interrompu leur
action on est plutôt dans cette
réflexion de voir comment on peut les
attaquer au portefeuille et c'est le
nerf de la guerre c'est l'argent et si
vous prenez l'argent et bien en général
c'est c'est ça fait bien plus de mal que
les années de prison
attaquer au portefeuille une méthode
qu'on appelle aussi la stratégie Al
Capone
celle qui avait permis de faire tomber
le célèbre par un Chicago pour fraude
fiscal
la police pense avoir trouvé le moyen de
faire tomber la brise de mer en
s'attaquant directement à son fonds de
commerce bar restaurant discothèque à la
recherche du moindre indice
et ça finit par payer
en octobre 1986 Robert Moracchini est
arrêté et inculpé pour abus de biens
sociaux
12 membres du premier cercle de la brise
sont mis en examen pour fausses factures
contre truquées ou fraude fiscale
et c'est autour d'un établissement situé
à l'Île Rousse que tout va se jouer une
discothèque dans le viseur de la brigade
financière
le challenger
le challenger c'est la brise c'est leur
bébé comment parce qu'ils avaient
investi énormément à l'époque c'était le
top c'était magnifique comme boîte
le gérant n'est autre que le frère d'un
des parrains de la brise un certain
Alexandre ruttini
le challenger avait été financé pour les
deux tiers avec de l'argent
occultes et pour complicité de
phosphatures c'est comme ça que nous
avons pu accrocher Alexandre routier
les policiers place sur écoute Alexandre
ruttini espérant un faux pas et de
nouveau renseignements sur les manœuvres
frauduleuses du clan Bastien
il tombe sur une étrange conversation
avec le maire de la ville
un échange qui va perturber le cours de
la justice
c'est le maire d'île rousse et s'avère
qu'il était également le député et
qu'ils étaient aussi rapporteur du
budget de la justice il y a même été
secrétaire d'État mondèche gros anciens
combattants
pierre passe Winny ancien résistant
proche du général de Gaulle est une
figure éminente encore ce un homme
au-dessus de tout soupçon
c'est donc une surprise pour les
policiers d'entendre Rutily membres du
premier cercle de la brise de mer appelé
ce vénérable élu de la République et lui
demander d'intervenir pour sauver la
discothèque des griffes de la justice
parce que Winnie ne peut rien contre
l'enquête mais il promet d'envoyer une
inspection au tribunal de Bastia
autrement dit faire de l'intimidation
auprès des magistrats
et quelques temps après une inspection
intelligente
[Musique]
vous dites il y a des personnages aussi
importants qui viennent nous chercher
des poux dans la tête parce qu'on fait
dans son travail dans des conditions
difficiles vous dites où on va quoi
[Musique]
alors que la justice s'étouffe la brise
elle respire de nouveau
car quelques mois plus tard il ne reste
plus grand chose des procédures qui
menaçaient ces florissantes à faire
[Musique]
pour la justice ça va être un coup
d'épée dans l'eau parce que ça va se
terminer sur des poursuites pour fraude
fiscale et des amendes qui ne seront
d'ailleurs jamais payés objectivement on
peut pas effectivement dire qu'il y a eu
de grands résultats et on s'interroge
sur
des liens très forts qui ne sont pas que
des liens d'amitié entre certains voyous
corses et certains élus
[Musique]
combien de ces élus sont intervenus pour
protéger les intérêts de la brise de mer
la justice elle ne peut que constater
les dégâts
et au final ça concourt au mythe qui les
entoure alors impunité alors qu'il a
justice avait vraiment agi à ce
moment-là elle aurait pu stopper net le
parcours l'histoire de la brise de mer
[Musique]
pour la brise l'histoire ne fait que
commencer
bientôt le clan Bastien va vivre ses
plus grands faits d'armes
[Musique]
et devenir le groupe de braqueurs le
plus dangereux du banditisme français
[Musique]
viens toi